the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay first midterm Lambert tool that's
if you look at the syllabus we have two
midterms arranged the first one is in
class the second why is it taking home
and now you can see why it's taking home
this problems would take time so but the
same way I think about taking home I
always thought of my own experience if I
give you on Friday you spend a whole
weekend night so what I am doing is a
giveaway on Monday I'd end up for the
lecture and we'll come in Wednesday at
the beginning of lecture
so it's a short pin hopefully any
question if you ask what are the
problems I put I posted examples so my
challenge is to make up the problem make
up the problems next few days that's
solvable okay and there are no problem I
can go every time I have to think harder
what other problem I can make that's
reasonable so okay any questions there
well maybe you have suggestions or
problems so let's review what we've been
talking in the last two lectures we were
solving the boards my equation look at
the classical size effects when the
carrier he carriers motorcycle ID with
the boundary so we took the simplest
configuration as Cynthia that has two
surfaces and to lecture ago we discussed
when you have a heat flow along the film
plan where they of course the he carrier
not just a parallel flow and say the
random velocity you can go hit the
boundary at boundary the diffusely
scatter
or the partially diffusely pushers
pecker scatter so and the second problem
that we do is in the last lecture is
let's now have the heat transfer in the
perpendicular direction when I say he'd
I hope now you're great it's a I can do
charge I can do say photon I can do say
molecule and in fact the molecular heat
conduction is a more difficult problem
than Eve or not that's because if I do
the gas molecule I have also a
concentration gradient so you in the
same material right the higher
temperature the if you think about ideal
gas law and the density will change
so when density change you also have a
mass diffusion you in the same mature
there's a mass diffusion that's an
integral equation so you actually have
to solve two integral equations together
for the molecular case for Fallout we
didn't we say it's just to say it's more
I will not consider the density
variation so it's a y integral equation
and the difference is in this case the
temperature is inside the integral right
so you and we use the relaxation time
approximation the board's my equation
itself is the first order differential
equation but I end because transport is
a long local right yeah when I say long
local I mean the heat flow at adding
point this is not just a local gradient
it depends on the temperature history
directly integration through the whole
domain so that's the non-local transport
and then we have to solve the integral
equation and the rarefied gas flow we
didn't solve this problem
but I discussed if you go to solve is
sort of for the combination of the two
because I have flow in the X direction I
have a source term that's a
relax but also I have the boundary that
constrain the moleculars and the
boundary scattered so if we solve this I
discussed the loosened minimum phenomena
and the velocity distribution now has
asleep so there is a discontinuity of
the Markos at the wall okay and I want
to say that this discontinuity so la
Marie if you say in 2005 all the
undergrad fluid mechanics heat transfer
we always say at the war the temperature
is continuous the velocity equals the
water temperature Lassa T that's the
long sleeve boundary condition right for
both temperature and for velocity and
the reality is there's always asleep
that sleep happens over one molecular
mean free path right so now the if let's
think about the air molecule mean free
path 100 nanometer right and if I have
sleep over a hundred nanometer but if I
deal with the meter square so that sleep
is too small to be actually observable
or of any significance so this is always
happening and except in the case of
liquid I will move on to the liquid
diverso okay so that's a the whether we
deal with more or less in the rigorous
in terms of solving the boards my
equation on the relaxation time
approximation and of course the
difficulty is now even for this simplest
problem like a heat conduction you
realize that we have to go solve an
integral equation which is by no means
trivial right so what I'm going to
introduce relaxed is some approximate
ways just attribute all the effects to
the boundary to the interface so we'll
use diffusion approximation using
Fourier law you
the inside the domain but at the
boundary I gave a sleep boundary
condition so how I should derive destiny
boundary condition and I want to
actually say one to show you a few
papers I wrote on this and it turns out
every field has this slip boundary
condition in the radiation there's the
so called Dazzler jump boundary
condition and in fluid mechanics there's
a first-order sleep second-order slip
and in heat conduction I mentioned
there's a temperature jump when we solve
the he say the perpendicular heat flow
right and electrical field
there's also interfacial resistance
electrical resistance so this is all
sort of related to what is this sleep
okay and and make more comments when we
go to look at these papers but the
diffusion approximation plus boundary
sleep
all right so what I'm saying is the
diffusion approximation of course is a
what that we've been talking chapter six
that's how we derive Fourier law Ohm's
law and all this continuum equations and
what I wonder is use this diffusion
approximation so the way I derive their
practice is the distribution function f
right equals F zero must have a x DF 0
DX right so this is a I am NOT writing
the force term for your electron you
have to write the force term right so
this was a day one that I will use to
derive the Fourier law the F is zero DX
is d F of 0 DT DT DX right so what I'm
going to do is the idea is that I'm
going to use this assume my this small
deviation from equilibrium this
distribution function apply to every
domain right to the interface ok so here
I have a boundary between two material
one and two and see the one side I have
distribution function right so f1 equals
F zero one must cow one we x1 D F 0 1 D
X right so this is a on the first side
on second side you can write this same
f2 equal F 0 to tau V X to DF 0 to D X
so we'll assume in that it's valid to
the boundary
say of course this is a proxy machine I
don't have a good justification in fact
it's a it's not so it's only you can say
ok maybe in the case of Knudsen number
is not very large right then you can say
most of the region is still diffusion
dominated but turns out this a sure work
out pretty wide range of losing them
in many cases and then I'm going to do
the heat flux right so if I do heat flux
I can do part of your flux any flux but
let me write the heat flux so the heat
flux and if I think about the inside
diffusion just to think about the
physics right this is an inside demand
we say this is a deviation so what it
means the transport is in the same
material did what diffusion really means
the distribution function f 0 is the
isotropic so it's a sphere right and
then say I have a small deviation and if
I my heat flow is in this direction so I
have in the forward I have a surplus in
the back our backward because the
velocity is the negative is I have a
deficiency it's really we emphasize it
is this region that's the surprise and
this deficiency this two part that
contribute to the left flux F of zero
itself when you integrate there's an
equal amount of heat going forward the
backward there's no left flux in the
same material right but things will be
different when I go to the interface
because the F 0 in the this first media
and the F is there a tool in the two
media could be different so now I do the
left flux or B so again I write start
with my summation of all the modes in
this case is what's the less flux across
the interface is all the ones that go
forward and that could transmit right
now I'll have to multiply but that
transmittance from 1 to 2 so I say okay
I do my typical polarization KX KY KZ
this is a side one so everything I put
into side one right that's why again I'm
in some in my mic wants
days and the way x1 so this is a way x1
say we x1 must be positive right that's
going from left to right so that means
my K x1 that's a we vector must be
larger than zero right the wave is going
from left to right and h-bar Omega and I
have f1 and I have then say how one to
to write the transmittance from 1 to 2
for example in chapter 5 we know how to
calculate transmittance from nail
formula for if you do photons and
similarly electron photons so this is
the half going from one the tool and
then icon the other half from 2 to 1 the
difference gives me in the left flux we
always been trying to do this right so
the other half is say P 2 on the second
side and this is a K x2 less than 0 so
this velocity is less than there also
that I put up way say plus side by say
is really say k y2 k z2 and the way x2
in this case is negative so the process
is really - so it's the LED difference
of the tool right so H bar Omega F - how
to - what okay so in a lot more same
material I do not write it into two
parts in the same material I just write
into my F and I don't say this okay I
sum up all post positive and maybe okay
and in that case F 0 like I said the
cancel this is the isotropic but in this
case if I substitute the f1 into here
and f2 I didn't write into here
and what they'll get is f 0 1 and F 0 2
and because the property on the two
sides are not the same you will not
cancel each other right and in fact if
you go back to chapter 5 yours you also
say that in the chapter 5 we talked
about the detailed balance right
so what I'll have is f 0 y if I just
think about this term f 0 1 and modulate
by tau 1 2 the rest is the weight at you
oh my god if I say that's the same and
here is a way to f 0 2 and H Omega tau 2
1 so I have this transmissivity from 1
to 2 and 2 to 1 I see you always have
that detail balanced you can write it
into one side only that's what we did in
chapter 5 ok so there's there's the
intermediate step mass I just too much
writing so I'm not going to explicitly
put it there so what I want is the
understanding so that's the first term
right F of 0 1 term now this is how V X
1 DF 0 D X this is a say determine when
I write in the same material I will
gather the thermal conductivity right if
I write in same material I sum up is in
the positive side and negative side the
2y is say it's really they add up they
did this is not a cancellation now
because this is a deficiency this is the
excess right you go to look at your mass
this two term action because the
velocity is reversed
it's a summation so but in this case I'm
doing half only kx1 right so it's larger
than zero so this is only this one off
with the the this part this surprise
spot and when I do this term is only in
this part right so I actually have a
half Q modulated by transmittance
because normally I in the same material
I do not have this transmittance issue
so if you follow what
say you put it in the math you convert
it into the Indigo what do you have is
so this what I'll get is some up I'm
still writing some I haven't converted
into integral vxy larger than zero you
can still do your polarization okay so
or either reading in koma KY 1 K Z 1 and
H bar Omega and power 1 through 2 and we
x1 F 0 1 months f02 so I'm using the
detail balance either detail balances at
the zero there if there's no temperature
difference the left to right equals
right to left so there is a relation
between transmittance of the two sides
so using that relation I could write
this detail balance so this is the 0 1
and 0 2 term but I have this power V XT
FD 0 term I just said it's a half the
queue right so if you do and the math
USA ok from 1 to 2 is tau 1 to 2 prime Q
over 2 and in fact you can write that
this is a Q 1 this is the flux on the
first side but the half because I'm only
doing positive part right and of course
I also have this transmittance and now I
put a prime because when you do this we
X square we XY square there is a sine
theta square so you integrate over angle
so this transmittance is the integrated
weighted transmitted side squared sine
squared cosine that's the when you
convert into spherical coordinate and
similarly I have tau 2 2 1 prime Q to
kill 2 2 1
okay that's on the other side this is a
diffusion if you again if you write the
Fourier law it will be minus K 1 DT DX
that's your cue right if it's same
mature that's what you would do right so
what I'm showing is now either interface
right because of the asymmetry of the
zeroth order term on the two sides I
don't have cancellation anymore and this
is zeroth order term if it's a so when I
have a queue I can put this to queue on
the other side combine right so I will
combine this took so Q 1 Q 2 Q 1 Q 2 if
there's no interface heat generation if
there's an interface heat generation I
have to be careful right if there's no
interface heat generation this Q 1 Q 2
should equal to each other because of
the continuity of the heat flow so all
this is a Q 1 equals Q 2 equals Q under
no heat generation so I plug in I have
one mass one-half tau 1 2 prime plus 2 1
prime Q equals now F 0 F 0 2 0 1 let's
say is related to temperature on the t1
on the first side at the interface so I
have this one is t1 and this is a t2
temperature right so I can use if the
difference is not large what I can write
is in two so this is right there that he
and we x1 larger than zero and we say k
y1 KZ 1 and again you sum up with a
polarization and tau 1 2
- and the way X 1 H bar Omega D F 0 1 DT
so I'm writing basically F is 0 1/2 0 -
really what it means is F 0 1 t 1 this
is f 0 2 F 0 t 2 because if you think
about bose-einstein distribution doesn't
have anything other than H Omega divided
by K T right so yourself with it just to
say they'd rather into difference
different short times they stamp your
difference across the interface so
laterally you see this television show
me I have a interfacial temperature drop
because of the asymmetry of my
distribution on the two sides right and
in the zeroth order term doesn't cancel
and of course this one you can again
convert or some machine into integration
and this conversion there's a slight
difference this is a tall one - here I
have we x1 right here when I took you I
have we x1 but also f1 have another of
tau YX 1 so that's a we x1 square in the
to kill we x1 squared sign see that
square we x1 just over sine theta so my
integral my averaging for this
transmittance is actually slight
different averaging weighted in terms of
angle but we write and so I'm going to
write so if you do this what you have is
you can write it into integral this is 0
Omega max and h-bar Omega D F 0 1 DT and
then set up States on the one side and
then what do you have on this side
is 1/2 0 to 1 to 1 to 2 mil de Mille so
this is a what comes from this size we
x1 has a sine theta and that mu 2 D mu
if we transmittance is 1 right if it
transmittance the 1 this gives me 1/2
neodymium right so this is a really one
force if I want to get this 2 times this
gives me the average transmittance
weighted over this science it ha we X 1
so this is a should give me 1 force this
is a gives me the specific heat oh I
forgot here is a way back so what this
one is really all together I can write
this as one force say x away and times
tau 1 2 are different the way the
average in terms of angle okay here I
use this a prime and there I use a
double Prime okay so what I have that
this one if I write together is the
other t1 force C way and how one to c1
we won on the first side and one two
transmitters right so this is a slightly
different than what you had in chapter 5
chapter 5 we did that they interface
thermal boundary resistance and the
water it didn't have is this two term
right but later on I discuss when I
discuss here there's a difference
between immediate temperature and
equanimity I'm sure you look go back to
look at derivation and in that case is
actually you come back at your ad is to
sort of terms so there's very similarity
acceptors say there is a little bit
difference in the angle the weight
itself because there we did not consider
this diffusion flux district
we did not consider F has this tall V
division and say flux okay so this is a
the what I say will apply to an
interface I have a temperature heat flux
and temperature jump I derive a relation
between flux and temperature
discontinuity either interface and you
can do for each problem you can apply
similar strategy to derive the type of a
jump boundary condition and as I said
for radiation there is one velocity
there's one and I'll show this some of
the paper it's also interesting I
remember after I arrived at MIT once
there was a professor professor Probst
name he brought in props team he came to
my office they brought me a paper he
said take a look at this paper I did a
jump boundary condition and if four full
tongues and it turns out that his paper
was one year earlier then they in the
field of thermal radiation we called
Easler boundary condition photons so he
actually derived the same because he is
he was a fluid mechanics right if I
guess and he did the extension to
radiation so maybe it should be called
the pristine boundary condition by the
way in this in the AFL is called these
okay what today why what's the
convenience with this right so let's
applied I'm going to deal with now the
heat conduction problem let's say this
is a medium one two three I have a sim
film sandwiched between two substrates
right to infinite substrate
I have heat flow here right and in each
region now because I'm assuming the
diffusion approximation is valid so
in each region I can use K let's say K 2
DT DX that's the diffusion but at the
boundary I know there is a discontinuity
at the interface and there's also not a
discontinuity at the interface so I can
represent this as three resistors the
interface resistor the internal resistor
and the second interface resistor right
so let's say this is a T 1 this is T 1
prime then this is a T 2 prime and this
is the T 2 right so because I the
interface I have the temperature
discontinuity between the two sides and
inside the material because this is the
two so I know Q for heat conduction
along this direction right I have Q he
flow equals K 2 T 1 prime mass T 2 prime
divided by D I'm applying the diffusion
approximation right to the boundary so
that's my Fourier law solution right I
have standard thermal conductivity times
times are different divided by the
thickness right and this is a flock so I
didn't do the area and then say I the 1
so I have Q I have then say T 1 minus T
1 Prime if we look at this this is a Q T
1 minus T 1 prime that's the interface
and then I have over one month tau 1 2
prime Crump's 2 1 prime over 2 this is
the averaging over the angle and I have
the C 1 we 1 over 4 tau 1 2 prime double
prime okay and in fact you will be
if I do the other side from two to one
in this case because here is my choice
right I read one to two in terms of the
property one to two I said if you use
the if you use the reciprocity right
they detail balance
it's your choice of whether to choose
side the wagon outside too and in this
case when I read this down I said oh it
would be much easier if I do say to way
too because Kate who is relate to say to
way to write the thermal conductivity K
- in the simplest form right we said as
a say tool way - and the mean free path
- okay so it would be easier if I do see
- way too but so this is at this
interface and this the third interface
here the second interface two to three I
can similar right Q in terms of for the
temperature t2 prime months t2 so at the
end if I measure the two temperature
depends on where you're measuring right
if I'm measuring the temperature on the
other side of this to medium and this
you could do your measurement for
example typical thermal interface
resistance measurement is the people put
a very long material they do a
thermocouple either one two three and
the measure temperature and they
extrapolate to the interface because
it's hard to stick a thermocouple
exactly at the interface right so in
this case okay it's that's your
extrapolate temperature on the same side
that's your extrapolate temperature and
then you you say okay if I use this
temperature to defy the temperature
difference I have this I need to
eliminate also t2 prime by similarly
other interface and if I add this all
this resistant together
so you will gather effectively so at the
end if you see my Q equals pay effective
thermal conductivity or dg1 much to t2
I'm using the temperature on these two
sides I say what's the interlayer
the factor with thermal conductivity
that includes the conductivity
conductance inside the layer and the two
interface resistance I add this up
together what I'll have is a K effective
thermal conductivity K be the bulk the
bulk a is just k2 here
k2 of course this if I take the ratio
and what I'll have is 3 T 4 gamma
yesterday you see here gamma or D is the
Lucent number for fula right and one
must 1/2 how one to prep how to one
front and tau 2 to prime double prime
plus 1 mass 1 again 1/2 how to 3 prime
plus 3 to 5 and the Tau to three prime
and plus 3 D or for gamma so it's
related to interface transmittance and
is related to say the ratio of the say
thickness over mm free pass okay so I
owe you thank you
so one thing that I can say that this
term is my Edition there okay and I see
this is an interesting saddle point is
real
this kind of addition make it very
consistent itself with the temperature
definition because the temperature in
the Fourier law is based on isotopic
distribution it's go in all directions
right and that immediate temperature
when we do sometimes we say okay let's
say this is incoming this is incoming
based on this incoming temperature
that's not a consistent with the Fourier
law definition okay so one success of
this edition is you look at the limit
when there's no interface okay when
there's no interface you should get the
Box thermal conductivity right and
typically say so will now interface that
means the transmittance equals 1 so this
is 1 this is 1 this is 0 this is 0 I get
back to 1 right and the most other way
this term is not included if you don't
do it consistent temperature definition
and this will be additional artificial
resistance so that's a success anyway
there I think it's a today rather than
looking at the literature I do want to
just show you some a few papers in this
case that I have to brag a little bit
about myself I wrote a few papers I want
to show hi the image show image
so the best way to so I this I when I
was a graduate student my wiser is a
very wise man and then he say okay the
best way to write that to learn my
subjects to write a paper you want to
work on a subject give you three months
write a paper on so that's the challenge
that I thought that it's a it's a pretty
good what challenge and it turns out
okay so I wrote a paper on this before
and this was a paper so I know there is
a boundary country there's these little
boundary condition right but the problem
is the temperature is not in the fourth
um that's of a photon transfer photon
transfer you measure a temperature by
sticking a thermocouple so that's a
different temperature definition so you
have to be very aware of how you define
how is your experiment so I use this
strategy I say apply basically this is
what I just shown here you do your you
do your summation and you convert into
integration and you can do see it
depends on you have to define
temperature you had you if you do
electron transport they have to define
your chemical potential okay voltage or
electrochemical protein you said you
have because these are all thermodynamic
quantities and so I took the same
strategy and apply for both electrons or
photons and again you have to be say
aware what exactly you're measuring in
the case of electron for example you
have metal semiconductor interface you
put the electrode there you will not be
measuring the voltage exactly at the
interface you know actually measure
were the averaging of them metal so it
turns out that I to do this I check a
lot of papers in electrical engineering
people do sir Monica emission modeling
and of course the Sarah Anna Commission
they are different some people when they
do Sarah Anna Commission it's a layer
inside the device and they would in that
case I see most of the paper actually
used to me is a wrong formula because
their formula will not approach the
limited when there's no barrier between
the layer for electron transfer is the
potential barrier at the interface that
ecause reflashing and so yeah so this is
the sort of shock a barrier situation
when you have a metal you have
semiconductor there is this Fermi level
and this is the electrical achieve from
conduction band to vacuum at the
interface the vacuum level is same so
the difference of a Fermi level and the
electrical affinity give you the
Schottky barrier and say you can have
two different semiconductor also at the
interface there's a barrier and I would
the challenge you if you're interested
in good read papers and that people
electrical generator have done a lot of
modeling and most of the time I just say
this paper just stick in the thermionic
emission formula and then into a device
and combined with refigure diffusion
equation I saw that's not consistent
okay maybe I'll this this is a say
hopefully electrical engineer won't be
offended yeah and when I say this
because that's reality of checking
literature okay next one so in fact I
already wrote this paper I had a fluids
there okay they slip flow for velocity
rarefied gas so say I said that's
beautiful right you do electron you do
for long
you also do molecule right and then I
asked a student mind which
the paper so I roll the paper I always
tried to write the paper a year doesn't
always happen no but say so the student
came back and he was very careful he's a
Christian he's a professor at Berkeley
he said there's a sign problem there I
said how could it be their sign problem
I used the same strategy applied to
fluid and I ended that with I couldn't
find there was the Indian design problem
so the fluid that was not applicable and
took me a while and then we wrote
another paper to fix that same problem
and this was a say the velocity sleep
right and this velocity sleep what
happens is the difference for the flow
day for this case is it turns out that
you can use again so as I said that
people did the first order slip second
order slip and to me that's always a
math okay you do your expansion you say
okay distribution function I expand the
first order and didn't work and let me
explain second order right and I see
that's a just a purely math based not a
physic based the argument and in fact
for radiation there this was reading in
the book you can check book there is an
expansion of a second order and the
trend is completely wrong it's reading
Ewing in the textbook right so because
of the the my argument is the board's my
equation is the first order equation and
then when you expand the second order
you're creating something strange so I
say okay I'm going to still use the
board managed equation first order
solution right to the boundary but what
I'm missing in the case of flu is say
there is a pressure driven term that's
the source of the Lucent minimum
emission before right so once I
understand that part we add this
impacting to
the the boundary condition and here are
some comparison okay so what do we have
here this is velocity distribution and
Loma is flow rate so this is a consider
Suginami I mentioned this is the board's
by equation solution right here is a
humor solution number so in verses D
over mean free path right so that this
was this is the when D is a lot much
larger than the mean free path
so that's continuum right you see this
is the first order correction so that's
what the people that's the Maxwell today
Maxwell did they actually this week okay
and then didn't work at the Lucent
minimum is a loosen number about one so
there are people expand to second order
and it doesn't have to loosen minimum
right but this is a much more over
predicting so I we did this sort of for
in between one that's not perfect but at
least I mean the right Ridge okay so the
point is this is a say you need to
understand physics when you do
approximations and one more paper want
to mention so this is a just a modified
boundary condition and then one - I said
okay let me go back and read modify the
boards my equation okay boys my equation
they the headache is face equation face
based equation right so you get an
integral equations and the Fourier law
is a real space equation so you can
solve finite difference all that much
easier so I say let me and also I
mentioned before there's I don't believe
this hyperbolic equation because the
hyperbolic is the only time it doesn't
take up a space issue there so one
strategy I took
is this split okay I see well this is a
boy's mind equation under relaxation
time approximation and let me split that
a carrier inside into two parts one part
comes from the boundary and when they go
a transport the inside there's a
scattered right there's a in scattering
from other direction or emission
there's also outgoing scattering so what
idea that is okay the boundary term is
just outgoing scattering and that part I
say it's a purely for boundary so I can
calculate say analytically based on the
view factor concept and then the the
other part is this diffuse scattering so
I can rewrite it into a form that's
similar to the continuity equation but
that's only part of it so with that I
call this but it's the diffusive
equation and so there this is the
solution comparison right this is a
continuity equation it has a the purpose
of tangling question is to try to solve
the issue of temperature discontinuity
not the infinite speed of the heat right
diffusion a parabolic equation I said
that if you have semi infinite media
surface a temperatures change the
solution exponent show decay means the
infinite way is not zero right it's the
exponential is small but it's not zero
that means it's the infinite speed so
the continuity equation is a wave type
of equation so there is a wave front but
the board's my equation there's a
for-real all this aborts my question
that's all sort of ballast is diffusive
equation it's a closer it doesn't have
this artificial
tanzanian type solution okay so the
story of this is I was happy so I was
going to I rode up the paper and the
light before I submit I said let me go
to check a radiation
right because I you just don't want to
make an outrageous claim if other people
I work like and as I went to check the
radiation and I found you know I'm not
the smartest guy in the world and people
write it down this well most of the time
we do research you find out that people
have done the so this is a town four
fold hung by this this guy are off and
in fact this reading in radiation
textbook I just I teach a religion
didn't read that carefully okay
so but that's a steady state and this is
a more general for for long for he can -
in your care about ransom okay so not a
sense you can do with understanding and
intuition and the best way to learn like
I said you write a paper on it you
understand better let me continue
so this is the chapter 7 which is about
the classic or size effects and now I'm
a moment to the next chapter what I'm
I'm talking when the talk is the coupled
energy come rushing and transport right
and then we say why if you see this book
aware why where is the energy conversion
we say is a nano scale energy conversion
and so the cup of the
so let's start chapter 8 so what this
chapter deal with is really think about
when we think about the energy
conversion right of course over from
narrow is this turbine or this a
microscopic is a really carrier energy
transformed from one type of carrier to
another form right from the photon to
electron and in fact I say even jar
heating the electron raise the
temperature of full lung that's the
interaction of the carrier that's an
energy conversion right so
microscopically is really if I think
about say light comes to an object right
the first step of that energy conversion
is light is absorbed and that absorption
either lift the electron from valence
band to the conduction band that's what
I want or excite a full lung and in the
case of electricity I don't like that
right so that's your part of your energy
conversion or when I have see a
conductor and I have electron flow in
the material conductor and what happens
is that the electron interact with the
full lung and again say sometimes you
want to minimize that right say you want
the better electric conductivity and
eventually say for whether you want to
say if you want to get a useful work out
it's a combination of this excitation
plus a transport well you feel excited
electron hole pairs right say you you
say okay my photon is energy and the
jacket enough I will need a hole behind
and get the electron here and the
question is whether you can extract out
right whether this electron can go to
your electrode
if you go electrode go to eternal you
win otherwise the nature what they want
is they are at a higher energy state
they won't go back right
since tends to be lazy minimal energy
and this go back would be relaxed back
to the bottom and it relaxed back to the
bottom and now there is a gap and they
can go relax through the gap by a medium
light or by emitting full-on right you
mean light if you use later that's what
you walk mother for photon you don't
want that right so so so so this is
really when you think about energy
conversion is how you can say steer this
process is towards the Russian that you
like to say and but say what I'm going
to do is to give you a very brief
introduction what's the mathematical
tool to do it right it's still based on
boards my equation but now let's look at
the interaction focus on interaction
term so if you recall in we talked about
the briefly Fermi golden rule what it
says if I have say original a system I
have these eigenstates I got from
quantum mechanical solutions right and
now I have a perturbation I have a
photon comes in for example and that
create a perturbation of the 2d energy
of the system
Muhammad Amir Hamiltonian that's a
pretty big breaching on top of already
they already the eigenstates right so
the Fermi go there Roy is ok this is the
initial States this is the final state
that's original solution allowable
solution and then the Fermi Golden Rule
tells me the rate of that process is 2pi
over h h bar and say initial to final
scatter matrix the author of the energy
the final state energy minus initial
state energy that's the Fermi Golden
Rule and the scatter matrix is related
to the wave function of the final and
the initial states and the perturbation
Hamiltonian so we have the scatter
matrix equals the final state wave
function the interaction perturbation
Hamiltonian and the initial state say we
function integral over the volume of the
interaction right so what I want to give
is a wine example this kind of a
scattering calculation extremely
involved and I say I want to use the
Wang exam to say people have done a lot
of work and if you want to look at that
you should check literature and this
wine example let's look at the electron
photon scattering right so if you think
about the how electron will go through
or a semiconductor right how electron
gets scared by photons and any process
you have to okay you have in the I think
I made those comments before fizzes and
even in reciprocal space also you have
to go think about the real event right
if you have a real world picture real
space picture what's happening then you
can describe that in terms of the
reciprocal space is just a math
mathematics
and if I think about say electron my
picture before is if you think about
crowning a panty model I have pure
article potential and that solution will
give me a bang gap right for example and
of course when I did with the for long
I have springe so the band gap powerful
this is let's say one dimensional
lattice depends on of course the lattice
constant right and depends on the
potential profile now what fallen does
is when your lattice is a vibrate those
lattice constants changing right the
lattice constant change you create I say
this fluctuation visually you can think
about that if my band gap depends on
lattice constant that is consonant is
vibrating so the electron let's say band
gap is a change in their due to the
lattice vibration and that created the
perturbation for the electron energy
level and created a scattering of the
electron so let's treat this problem and
so the perturbation to the Hamiltonian
and in the 1d let's say okay electron is
close to the band gap is a function of
the lattice constant and the
displacement and of the each lattice
point right so this will give you a
delta a and the master the initial
steady state so this is they say in the
1d right if I do a 3d situation I do I
can do an expansion right so if I do a
Taylor expansion it's do you say D I do
on D X times a so in three
this can be written as equals za and the
divergence of the atomic displacement
vector you okay and this is the za is
they call the deformation potential za
is the how the bandgap
check the conduction band you say okay
will change as a function of the volume
change of the crystal so if you squeeze
the crystal how the back never change
right so this is a a is the deformation
called deformation potential and now I'm
going to use this Hamiltonian perturbed
Hamiltonian back into the Fermi golden
rule and try to say what is this matrix
scatter matrix from I to F right so this
is the next part and the way to do it is
you have to you say you are going to
integrate over the volume your initial
function and your final wave function
and those are the wave functions of the
electron because I'm looking at the
electron gets scattered by lattice
vibration right so this is the lattice
vibration how is perturb the Hamiltonian
of the electron so physically say what
we have is that you can have an electron
at certain we vector energy come in and
interact with a lattice wave and let's
say at a certain wave vector and a
certain frequency and this is you can be
come by write the energy of the photon
is given to the
electron so you gather the moment energy
new momentum new energy free electron
this is the union elastic a process a
phonon disappear right you could also
have the process where electron with
certain energy momentum and split into
another electron at this different
energy momentum with a follow
create a former okay so that's the
interaction process and mathematically
what it was say is I want to plug this
into the scatter matrix but I say for
the say let's say the wave function
right I can use if I now the wave vector
I can use the pram with representation
right the wave vector the wave function
is proportional exponential I K are you
have energy frequency also in there but
this is the energy part is actually
taken care of by this Delta function in
the Fermi golden rule you could keep
that everything together you'll see the
lecture coming all over this Delta
function and now if I look at the
displacement of the atom write out the
displacement of the atom again now you
can go say this is a each space each
point in the crystal could be have a
different displacement but we did a
fully or transform before write any
function you can express in terms of
sine cosine that's what a Fourier series
this is the reciprocal lattice
representation so rapid I said we can
say different wave vector of the and you
kill and exponential minus I Omega T
must kill that are eventually this Omega
T will be merged into the energy into a
part of the energy
conservation but I righted it down here
because to say when we think about the
energy of the lattice vibration we need
a say 1/2 MV square one sitting at that
time a derivative will give me oh my god
ok so this is a now if I go to plug in
this two wave functions right into these
scatter matrix and that's water
so the scatter matrix from k to k prime
this is the electron scattering matrix
we vector right that means to say I have
1 is the K the you need either initial
final the other is K prime initial final
and what I have then is this one could
be written as Z a over way and because
I'm substituted a in the ca-300 tomia
comedy Patel Hamiltonian and then I have
when I substitute the yolk the this H
Prime into the expression I will have a
cure I kill time CU q and exponential
must I pay prime plus kill mass K times
R you see here I didn't carry that month
I Omega T term just look at this space
shuttle ok so the point I want to make
is here if you look at this expression
what really scatter follow UQ so for
fall on this is the plan wave this is a
photon wave vector I say we vector
Direction fall on wave propagation
direction this is a lattice displacement
direction right whether it's a
transverse wave if it's a perpendicular
to kill or
it's a longitudinal wave if it's in same
direction of Q right so because of this
deformation potential at the end and my
scatter matrix is the dot product of Q
times you immediately tells you the
transfer is falling on here do not
scatter electron right this because this
is a zero and it's a longitudinal photon
that was scatter electron that's one
secondly if we look at this integration
plan wavy integration this will be
rapidly sine cosine function average
over the volume volume right because
this is exploding sure and I say complex
function is either sine and cosine if
your average is sine cosine over a large
number you know it's a zero
so unless those exponent is zero the
rest of this is all there right so what
do you have here essentially with this
mass you gather the momentum
conservation because when this one is
zero or it's a say 2 pi of reciprocal
lattice vector you get this one will not
be a zero function so what you have is a
delta K prime plus Q and because I have
this a decay so what is what it means is
a K prime plus kill mass k equals zero
that's the momentum conservation
so that's H K is the electron momentum H
curl is the phonon movement so it came
from laterally from this integration and
you in fact if this one is rather not
zero is the equals of gee-gees
reciprocal lattice vector we talked
before right and that's still fine you
also you integrate that you will not be
zero because you get a too high
i 2pi and by say for you like
fall on this seldom happen it's a
typically you know para Guardian
semiconductor because the in
semiconductor this is a conduction band
and most of the electron is at this
location so it doesn't need to say with
G is the reciprocal lattice vector PI
over a that's a very large momentum
there so that the read of that process
don't happen often it's a typical normal
process okay so you essentially you can
also relate the kill you velocity the
amplitude of all the lattice
displacement to they say how many fall
on you have okay so this is all related
to energy right one is the photon
picture this is a displacement is the
actual movement there so if you think
about the energy
because I want related to temperature so
energy conservation say the the weather
weather we have is 1/2 MV square right
this is the kinetic energy plus
potential energy one-half KX square that
u equal to the total energy of them
phonons so if I do that what I have or
what I have is one-half Rho V Omega
square and the new Q square so this is a
kinetic plus potential energy equals H
bar Omega and kill and kill is the
number of photon at that temperature
with this momentum right at the
equilibrium that's they are boards my
status no they've was Einstein
statistics okay so this one thank you is
a function of the temperature Omega at
the equilibrium so the reason I do this
is so that I can write the final
expression in terms of different
temperature what's the electron phonon
interaction okay I convert this
displacement vector in terms of the the
number of photons so if you do this you
go to say essentially write the
scattering term DF DT and this term
let's say let's look at this first one
we look at the photon emission although
the follow this term so from K prime say
absorb a photon so any heat and
animation process go to another electron
and for this process it is say when we
sum up this is the transfer this is a 1
right from K to K prime or K prime okay
you can write different six slight
different forms so what I have here is
this is the sum up or Q and the to PI H
bar in the front and the Q Square and
the h za square and to roll B Omega and
enqueue so this is the scattering matrix
Fermi Golden Rule I'm applying Fermi
golden rod 2 pi H square right and then
now when I scatter I say from how many
electrons I have either K prime because
this is going from K prime to K so
that's the Fermi Dirac statistics I have
okay how many electron I have at this K
prime but then when I scatter into K I
have to see how many states are empty
but this is the Pauli exclusion
principle right so this is a K and then
I have this Delta functions K prime kill
2 K that's a result out of my scatter
matrix and then I have my energy
conservation another Delta L for e this
is the father energy equals the sum of e
prime plus H Omega so that's the T prime
minus H Omega very complex but people
actually did this ok
and if you go to read papers there
sometimes you people still do it
electron photon scattering is very
difficult and this is one of the four
possibilities so you actually have four
terms like this this term we talked
about
is from a prime to K by absorber for now
I can have from K prime to K 2 e media
for now so right this is both of this
process you increase the number of full
electron in the k-state
I can have a reverse the K is scattering
out to K Prime right by absorbing Amira
fauna so there are four process that
give you the lab balance or food again
in the board's my equation that
scattering term we talked before in
terms of two particle collision model
now I'm doing electron photon collision
model and the point is that you see at
the end you gather all those products
okay that's temperature dependent and
when you want to solve with the board's
my equation to solve for this
distribution it's a it's a pretty
tedious let's say the people have who
have done a lot of work on this we say
Shockley right chocolate is the human
der of the transistor you look at the
papers they study all those and there
are other people like home we see very
solid work and so the wouldn't you put
this into boards my equation you like I
said this is only one of the four
process therefore terms and in the 60s
so the people don't do computers so this
is all done analytically okay so I
actually repeated derivation if you read
the book I did it I had I remember when
I did the electron photon scattering and
I had a factor I couldn't reconcile
what's the difference so I have a factor
of who PI or PI one third difference
from their derivation so I put my result
there I couldn't find the word was a
difference
okay so now what happens is the default
so if you say this are all the
scattering term right so I see the
anytime you are Kerry interacting you
can do this if you want to calculate
there was a photon absorption you your
photon comes in either perturbation and
it was excited electron holes and you
have to look at the whether there's
empty States for the other electron to
actually be lifted from here to here so
those are all the scattering term you
can write into the right hand side for
each process the board language and I
they add let's go back to the boars my
equation DF DT plus way dot R F dot say
F over cm so this give me a and so I'll
have to put a F and this is the
scattering term we say for each process
you can write all those different say
summation in the garage and you can
solve it okay and my last point is here
is that in the previous chapter we use
relaxation time we couldn't deal with we
just say this is so what we did before
is this is minus DF D 0 over tau right
but I say that's a little bit cheating a
lot of cheating right so it's a huge
integrating right in the very simple
form and you see the if you read the
book electric engineer very often what
people do is the F equals even term plus
a all term okay
author
okay and you you substitute this back
into this scattering indigo does this
expressions and you find out that a DF
DC for the roughly DF DT the scattering
term can actually write into this this
due to the even term and the due to the
R term and turns out the R term could be
roughly right into relaxation time the
human term cannot what the human term
represent is the inelastic scattering
electron for long when they scatter they
lose energy and so they have energy
change right and for those kind of thing
you cannot in fact that you go through
this you say expression you say it's
roughly is a TEM STP it's the effective
temperature difference between electron
Cola times this electron photon
scattering the coupling energy coupling
coefficient so for elastic scattering
rigorous speaking the relaxation time is
not valid okay so we were done a lot of
what I said this approximation we did
before we saw boards my equation it was
say say really just using those terms
but I say when there is a difference
between electron and fall on temperature
if you pass the current through a
material and you do some of those
coefficient your plug in and you'll find
out that your normal conditions the
difference between electron and falling
temperature difference is very small so
this term still is not important in
normal conditions but it becomes very
don't you have a transient term like a
you have a laser for example we do
experiment the pump rope I shoot the
laser on the metal and I can observe
very hot electrons and so you're like
Tron could be much harder than full-on
temperature or if you have a MOSFET
right say you have say mas father you
have what sauce you have a drain term
you have a gate and it turns out that
the electron temperature electrons gain
energy when you apply voltage and on the
green side they can be a thousand times
degrees okay much harder than the
lattice and so for those kind of kids
cases you need be come more careful and
I will talk more on along those lines
you